[Musique] étrangère n'a
jamais été envisagée par mon père en
fait, il n'a pas été facile pour moi de
le convaincre qu'il devrait même y avoir une
exposition, c'est un homme très privé, un
humble et modeste
[Musique]
assistant
et pour moi
[  Musique] de
très beaux bijoux de haute qualité faits à la main
sont toujours très recherchés par
divers groupes de personnes et Carbon
French est l'un de ces ateliers qui est
capable de le faire au fil des années.
Carbon French a employé des
artisans hautement qualifiés, dont beaucoup sont
formés à l'étranger.  En Europe en
particulier et en France et en Ukraine donc
André dit qu'il avait parfois l'impression d'
être un chef d'orchestre dirigeant un
orchestre de talents incroyables
différents types de lampes soit en bois, soit en bois
incrusté de véritable craquelé et cela
n'inclut pas l'époque de mon père cette
collection et The Works  c'étaient
vraiment les projets passionnés de la
vie de mon père, c'étaient les pièces dans lesquelles
il mettait son amour de son art
strictement pour l'amour de la beauté et de l'art
merci
[Musique]
règlements familiaux
dédiés à
l'étranger
[Musique]